to paint a picture my father had full
rain in this house he had full rain he
had full control from when they ate to
where they slept this is a family who
say they spent years being coercively
controlled I was trapped wherever I went
if I went to any organization they would
just always refer me back to the police
but Sharon and daughter Emma not their
real names never did report him to the
police
they claim Ricky Jones prevented them on
one occasion I said that if he didn't
stop what he was doing to me and the
children I would go to the police
without him
and then he came to me and said I've
been in in work and I've sorted it Go in
if you want to to the police
but they know you're coming and they
won't listen to a word that you say they
now want action to help others
I believe I'm not the only one there
must be lots and lots of women out there
that want to do something and are too
frightened rooting out a couple of bad
apples isn't going to do anything and
there needs to be an overhaul it needs
to be public inquiries there needs to be
an external organization set up for for
anybody that doesn't feel safe reporting
to the police Ricky Jones took his own
life in 2020 while searching his phone
for evidence of the abuse Emma uncovered
another horror messages between her
father in offices at gwent police
exposing an alleged culture of racism
misogyny and homophobia inside the force
the content first uncovered by the
Sunday Times is now at the center of an
investigation being run by Wiltshire
police
addressing concerns raised by the family
Gwen police told Sky News the initial
complaint raised by the Jones family did
not include the conduct matters now
emerging and as new issues come to light
we will continue to take Swift and
robust action we continue to be
horrified by the comments and material
shared by retired officers and a small
number of serving officers these
behaviors and attitudes have no place in
Gwen police
we've worked with victims of crime
including survivors of domestic abuse we
would encourage any person who doesn't
feel confident in reporting to us that
they can speak to our partner agencies
with whom we work closely so that they
can receive support and help they need
I was scared of the police before I was
scared of my dad and then
I went through that device
and I've seen how they operate I see
how they treat victims of police
perpetrators and and now I'm terrified
of them
down Whitehead Sky News in South Wales
uh just to let you know if you're
affected by that story and want to talk
to someone you can call the National
Domestic Abuse helpline free on 0808
2000 2470 808 200247